Xtreme Everest 2 is building
on our previous experiment.
And what we're looking at is the
staged ascent to altitude,
as the air gets thinner and
thinner, trying to understand
how humans adapt to the low
levels of oxygen that we're
experiencing at altitude.
The expedition is a huge
research project and we've set
up a number of laboratories to
test volunteers at they ascend
higher and higher up the
mountain to Everest base camp,
where we are here.
When we were here initially, the
temperatures at night were
dropping to almost minus
30, which is quite
difficult to sleep in.
And when you get up in
the morning it's
still minus 10 or so.
The investigative team is very
cold, as is all the equipment.
So it's a hard, hard life.
Not only is it an absolutely
brutal environment, you're
pushing towards the so-called
death zone.
It's very, very hard to live
there both from the oxygen
availability, and
the temperature.
You're living in tents on broken
ground and moving ice.
So absolute heroes of this whole
endeavour, alongside the
volunteers who are being tested,
are the researchers
who lived there for
three months.
This place is nuts.
So where we are now, 5,300
metres above sea level, and
there's approximately 50% of the
oxygen in the atmosphere
that you're breathing, than
we will find at sea level.
We will work in places where
patients are short of oxygen
for diseases of the lungs or
hearts, or other parts of the
body mean there's less oxygen
available for the organs.
And some people couple with that
and some people don't.
If we look at a group of, let's
say, 100 people admitted
with a pneumonia, you treat them
in exactly the same way
and about 25% shake it
off straightaway
within a week or so.
There's about 50% that we need
to bring into hospital and it
takes them a month or
so to get better.
Just another 25% that crash
and burn within a week.
And they die as a result of
exactly the same pneumonia.
Now, a fundamental difference
between those is how quickly
they can adapt to the
lack of oxygen.
And that's exactly the same sort
of thing we see up here.
25% don't notice it, 50% find
it difficult, 25% find it
really hard.
We have very strong evidence now
to say they're exactly the
same mechanisms.
And if we can understand that,
we can come up with different
treatments, and possibly even
different drugs that will move
everyone into that rapid
adapting group, and therefore
increase survival.
One of the striking things is
how tolerant the Sherpa people
are of the low levels
of oxygen.
You look at them, they don't
look like incredibly
physically fit athletes.
But when you see their
performance--
their ability to carry high
loads, their ability to work
when we're suffering, even
when we're acclimatised--
it makes you ask the question,
why are they so different?
Now, there's been numerous
experiments in the past on
Sherpas, and classical
physiology tells us that they
are no different.
But now we have questions that
couldn't be asked before.
It's something going on at a
cellular level, right down in
the tissues, in the muscles.
And within there it's the fuel
cells, they're called the
mitochondria, where the
oxygen is used.
And that's what we're
exploring in
great detail this time.
The three important things that
we're looking at are the
micro circulation, the
mitochondria, and nitric
oxide, which may control those
two, are very relevant to the
kind of things that we see in
our intensive care patients.
And it may be that we need to
shift the way in which we
treat intensive care patients
based on what we find here.
One of the big parts of Xtreme
Everest 2 is looking at
nitrates, which are little
chemicals that are released
into your bloodstream and help
to change how big or how small
your blood vessels are.
So we think if your cells are
low on oxygen, then your body
might be releasing more of these
nitrate chemicals in
order to deliver more oxygen.
It's a bit like if you've got
a traffic jam on a road and
you get the builders in to
build more lanes so more
people can travel at
the same time.
So nitrates are a bit like
the builders, perhaps.
We believe that we're right
on the cusp of making a
fundamental discovery that will
have a major impact on
our patients back at home.
The science of it is just
so interesting.
And to be able to come here and
not just do science, but
see this is amazing.
The amount of data that we will
be able to take home from
this, and analyse, and hopefully
change the way that
people think about low levels
of oxygen in critically ill
patients, if we can change that,
then it will definitely
have been worth coming up here
time and time again.